after news broke yesterday that North
Korean leader Kim jong-un is threatening
to cancel the June 12th peace summit
Democrats and their never Trump poodles
rejoiced yes they did well the North
Korean dictator's Vice foreign minister
is taking issue with u.s. military
exercises underway with South Korea but
North Koreans say it is a provocative
military ruckus jointly conducted with
the South Korean authorities that
threatens the peace process well even
though these are exercises that are
conducted every single year well the
North Koreans are further agitated by
John Bolton suggestion that the Hermit
Kingdom should commit to a complete
denuclearization similar to Libya in
2004 well that really set the North
Korean Foreign Minister off he said it
is essentially a manifestation of an
awfully sinister move to impose on our
dignified state the destiny of Libya or
Iraq which had been collapse due to the
yielding of their whole country's two
big powers well North Korea's
vacillation and the bait-and-switch
routine that they're pulling here is
kind of typical and it was probably
expected by the Trump team but what I
saw and what I heard when I woke up this
morning was even more disturbing than
what North Korea's pulling here American
commentators wearing their see I told
you so smirks reveling and what could be
bad news for their own country they were
preemptively dancing on the grave of the
peace summit and why for the sole reason
that it would embarrass president Trump
if you would look at history you would
be a little more what's the word careful
about being braggadocious I mean this
Donald Trump has an aversion almost he's
allergic he's allergic to to complexity
an allergic to history North Koreans
consent that desperation on Trump's part
and now they're kind of RAD on
his cage to see how desperate he's going
to be for this agreement I think there
was a tendency especially from the
President to be sort of doing an endzone
dance in anticipation of having scored
something but frankly he's doing an
endzone dance on his own 20-yard line
you think he ever played football anyway
former Obama CIA chief John Brennan with
his usual smug self-satisfied dissing
genuineness each I'm then saying this
turn of events is unsurprising since
Donald Trump seems enamored with a fire
aim ready policymaking process that is
fraught with pitfalls as well as
potential disasters pitfalls potential
disasters to me it sounds like the CIA
under Brennan's leadership but maybe of
the media we're not so obsessed with all
things stormy or absurd Russia collusion
theories or intro White House rivalries
well maybe they'd be able to see how
petty and yes an American they seem
today we're talking about the
possibility of doing something
profoundly good for the United States
and for our allies throughout Asia
achieving peace and bringing North Korea
out of the dark ages of human rights
that's a critical objective and let's
not forget Trump has already done the
unexpected he has helped liberate
American hostages from North Korea's
hands and opened up the possibility for
real peace he's changed the dynamic the
State Department today said they have no
official indication from North Korea
that the summit is off and that the
president is planning right now to be
there every United States citizen
regardless of their political party or
personal feelings toward the president
should want the summit between Trump and
Kim jong-un to happen and of course for
it to be successful the lives of
hundreds of thousands of innocent people
are potentially at stake here ending the
possibility of thermonuclear war that's
a little more important than scoring
cheap political points
mr. president II didn't vote for don't
you think and that's the angle